on voyait mal et sa mère enfant blond
liées telles sommes tous voulu y aller
dit ici avec jérôme où le canot été
plaqué au fond de la rivière
pris dans les branches c'était
impossible de plongée même pour moi
il plonge jeux olympiques
sylvie bernier bonjour de plaisir à
s'entraîner avec vous à titre de
marraine du programme nager pour
survivre de la société nationale de la
prévention danois jan est aussi auteur
on le sait de ce livre le jour je n'ai
pas pu plonger histoire de raphaël votre
neveu jusqu'à quel point c'est pour
raphaël que vous faites ce que vous
faites au jour cette année pour cet
événement c'est vraiment parfait et
c'est vraiment pour toute la famille
aussi ça a été long après dix sept ans
avant que qu'on décide de revenir sur la
place publique de revenir où on a laissé
17 ans à la suite du dépôt grand quête
du coroner on avait mentionné lors d'un
point de presse un jour on aimerait
sensibiliser la population aux risques
qu'il peut y avoir au risque d'activités
nautiques aquatique
jean françois dubé m'a montré comment
les choses doivent être faites
les mêmes en faisant tout selon les
règles de l'art les incidents peuvent
arriver
[Applaudissements]
la posture d'aujourd'hui qui doit faire
la promotion
physiquement actif donc il faut que je
sois capable de doser entre je veux que
les gens bougent
je veux que les gens continuent à avoir
du plaisir sur le bord de l'eau dans une
embarcation mais avec cette conscience
qu' il ya des risques à l'eau et qu'on
soit sur le bord d'une piscine familiale
il fait 30 degrés on est toute la
famille mais il ya personne qui est
attitré à surveiller par exemple un peu
comme un conducteur désigné la même
chose sauveteurs désigné donc
aujourd'hui on revient mais on veut
vraiment sensibiliser la population à
faire attention c'est ça qui est
incroyable parce qu'on le fait année
après année depuis des décennies on va
prendre le temps de regarder quelques
chiffres sur un tableau simplement par
rapport à l'an dernier 22 juillet l'an
dernier 34 noyade cette année une 37
oui ça baisse et au fait d un mais ce
besoin il est encore là encore et
toujours
qu'est ce que ça va prendre pour que
quand cette prise de conscience heures
soit plus s'imprègne davantage je prends
souvent l'exemple la ceinture de
sécurité dans la voiture ça fait 40 ans
l'eau qui a l'obligation d'attacher sa
ceinture de sécurité et au départ on y
croyait plus ou moins ya même des gens
qu'ils aiment en jeu pour vous d
attacher la ceinture donc on est en
train selon une norme sociale de porter
sa veste de flottaison a des fois c'est
pas cool en aidant on va on est imprégné
on est sur un bateau de plaisance rendre
portent une adresse de flottaison et
pourtant et pourtant et pourquoi la nasa
peut sauver les vies 80% du temps que
lorsqu'un accident ou une noyade mais
les gens
les gens qui étaient alentours ont dit
qu'ils pensaient pas passer par dessus
bord d'un accident et la personne ne
portait pas sa veste de flottaison
s'élever portait probablement que ça
serait terminée par une anecdote en fin
de journée mais malheureusement on ne
portait pas de veste de flottaison c'est
quoi un changement de culture
impressionnant il faut opérer de da
proches notre relation à l'eau à la
sécurité nautique qui aquatique encore
quelques chiffres qui en disent long sur
la situation cette année qui nous disent
à quel point les scénarios peuvent être
variés même bernier les noyades de cette
année dans le bilan de cette année sur
des plans d'eau naturelle 69% des actes
et rivières les fleuves les ruisseaux
10% les prix des piscines résidentielles
et puis la basse à savary pour le reste
on voit ici le gros des noyades ou ça se
produit naturel mais le noisy naturel
dans ce qu'on fait nos lacs rivières
fleuves
si vous partez ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
assurons nous de bien connaître notre
environnement
donc chaque rivière olt ses
particularités
elle était sinueuse le débit le débit
change très rapidement si une forte
pluie deux heures avant le début change
la température de l'eau vous savez que
une rivière l'eau peut-être à 400 degrés
malgré le fait qu'il fait 30° qu'on est
en plein mois de juillet 4 5 degrés si
on chavire de façon inattendue et qu on
est en culottes courtes et qu'on n'a pas
de vêtements il au terme et quelques
secondes on peut être totalement
désorienté et on peut rapidement être en
hypothermie
donc c'est de prendre le temps de
s'informer de palais se louer quel nom
un kayak et de s'aventurer sur une
rivière que l'on ne connaît pas eu
l'excellent résidentiel
si le résidentiel depuis 2010 beaucoup
de réglementation je dirais que le
ce qui reste aujourd'hui c'est tout
l'aspect surveillance son frère visite
on prend pour acquis que tout le monde
surveille mes personnes surveillent donc
chaque seconde est important une noyal
c'est sûr noir et c'est silencieux
l'enfant ne se débattre au pot il ne le
dira pas donc il faut aussi silencieux
et ça ne prend que quelques secondes ont
souffert d une et c'est une personne qui
comprend mieux si bien beaucoup là mais
tout à fait ça a été long parce que je
dis toujours que derrière toutes les
statistiques et les chiffres que vous
avez mentionné
chaque dessin est un drame pas pour une
semaine deux semaines est un drame pour
la vie et chaque noix yable noyade était
vital elles sont toutes évitables
la majorité d'entre elles donc il faut
les prévenir et merci de prendre le
temps d'en parler parce que moi tout ce
que je souhaitais que tout le monde ait
du plaisir sur l'eau dans l'eau mais en
toute sécurité
merci infiniment sibérie donc si elle
est trop chère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]